thank you for allowing me to to talk at
this Gus meeting really quite a quite a
large gathering it looks great so many
people interested in this topic I have
to say my my talk has changed almost
completely from what I started out
trying to put together this talk a few
weeks ago where I was focused on what
are the issues what are we trying to do
what are our goals what are we trying to
get to because of all of the interest
and all the things that we've come out
since then I'm bypassing what our goals
are together and let's say the people at
least most of us here I think we're
together I'm saying let's like put it as
an assumption that we know what
motivates that we have to share data
right so let's not spend time I saw I've
taken out of my talk the motivation for
why we share data why we want to share
research data what we try to get out of
that and focus instead on two problems
that are growing with trying to share
data and I specifically focus on that in
the spirit of brainstorming say okay
here's some ideas about how we might get
over those problems and that's basically
the point of my talk as opposed to all
of the process stuff that I've usually
given talks about so let's start with
those common assumptions right that we
need to share data we need to put them
in repositories discipline-specific I
want to come back to that a little bit
as opposed to sort of like just a
neutral repositories that don't don't
have metadata with them or something
controlled vocabulary so that you can
join them up and do analytics on them
normalized etc so that you can do
something larger with the data play into
the all of the hype around big data if
you will but I'll talk a little bit more
about that so right now the problem
number one is a small portion of data
are being shared right so that's why
part of why we're here and there's lots
of reasons for that and so there's lots
of barriers to sharing the data lots of
things that prevent researchers from
openly sharing their data making them
available right away lots of issues
going on there and so maybe we can think
brainstorm a couple of ideas about how
to get over some of those barriers part
of my talk will be about that and then
there are problems with sustainable
funding for those databases which are
growing enormously the data themselves
growing at least I doubling every year
and the databases themselves
even in some of the hot areas going
between 10 and even upwards percent of
number of databases per year so there's
obviously we're heading towards a
funding issues for keeping them going
and I'll talk a little bit about that so
the point of my presentation so after
this you can go to sleep which is why I
made the the slides back the main points
of presentation is we can we can remove
some of the barriers by sort really
developing rigorous processes and
rigorous controlled vocabularies and
everything and get simplicity and
efficiency out of doing data management
well and most importantly providing
credit and the right credit applications
back to the researcher for doing that
sharing and tracking that and so forth
there's a lot to be done in that space
but but it's something that we I think
that we've got a fair handle on Lisa
start and I think it's also possible to
create sustainable funding models for
some of these databases and there's a
couple of well maybe the radical maybe
they're not ideas that about how we
might work together to do that so big
data versus research data a lot of
people there's so much hype around big
data huge datasets and a lot of science
doesn't have large data sets they have
small dates that they may have many of
them but they have small data sets but
also the emphasis is a little bit
different so if we take this is the life
cycle the data one data life cycle that
we've structured our symposium around
and the the big data focus tends to be
on well if we had all these data we had
them all together maybe I should tip
this up early this is what we should do
what we could do right we could analyze
them we could get new insights from all
of the data by putting them into a giant
repository and doing analytics on this
and of course I'm sure all of you are
familiar with the fourth paradigm book
that came out sponsored by microsoft
conference about taking science and
moving science forward more rapidly and
all of that I don't want to it into that
height but all of that is around if we
had the data and it were normalized and
it were joined up and it were all of
these things that are very very
important and difficult to do to get the
data together then we could get more
value out of them and do that kind of
analytics and that's a big if and in
fact research data is still back here
still back here with the core problems
of annotating the data normalizing the
data joining them up in a lot of cases
okay that's maybe that's the rebound
effect or maybe that's telling me my
time is up I'm not quite sure what the
story is but anyway so so research data
really needs to focus on different
problems that are before we get to the
great analytics things we can do on the
data and again many of these datasets
are smaller so here's I just picked up
some random we're going to hear later
today about fig share a great repository
for helping you store your data there's
a lot of other databases out there for
doing that one of the interesting things
I want to point out is what the
Australian national data services
they've done I think last count they've
got about sixty thousand different
isolated data sets and in their
repository building up but these are
data sets that have not been joined up
normalized you can't do analytics cross
easily horizontally across these data
set and they have set a new vision for
saying what their focus over the next
few years is going to be move the data
sets from a bunch of isolated data sets
into more of a discipline specific
repository approach I'm those are
putting my words on you can see their
words up here but I'm putting my words
on on what they're they're trying to do
but that's really what it's about right
is getting more value out of it getting
those data sets that have the same
common terminology the same normalized
values and the same understanding about
the where they came from the methods
that were created they're used to create
them very important for example in
imaging well you can't just say I
created this image especially a 3d MRI
image or something like that I created
this image and compare it to something
else you have to say exactly what
transforms you did on that to create the
data so it can be compared with
something else very important metadata
work that needs to be captured as part
of this as part of this effort so
problem number one barriers to data
disclosure why aren't people sharing it
and I just highlighted a couple of
things to focus on credit right getting
credit back and obviously one of the key
ways to do that is to link the pay dirt
paper paper and data sets together a lot
of work great work going on doing that
that gives you citation and so forth but
data sets at least now this is an
opinion which you know there's probably
200 60 different opinions about
this are in the room but that I think
data sets are going to become more and
more things by themselves where the data
sets in some cases we're working with
researchers who are publishing their
data sets fruit more frequently and more
granularly than guts done in the paper
later and those data sets are being
reused as part of analytics and they
need to get credit for that and I know
some examples of data repositories that
are starting to do that when somebody
does an analytic that goes across
multiple data sets they monitor that and
they give reports back to the user that
says your data set was used for this and
that's clearly going to be part of the
infrastructure of credit in the future
and that's a really important thing for
getting this this data going again
working with researchers to help
increase that and then I've just I've
taken this this is one of those slides
that I've taken around to now I've
talked to what six or seven funding
bodies and research institutions and so
forth to sort of validate the list and
stuff and and and I think this is that
probably most of us in this room
understand what's going on here but
there's ways we can get around that and
that's providing really help in getting
that over so just a little side there's
a little sidetrack just for to give
Peter some ammunition and his next talk
you start mentioned talking about
supplemental data supplemental data is
an approach that was taken a few years
ago we'll just add supplemental data
sets to the published paper as it goes
in the the the publisher will put those
aside on the together with the paper and
put them out there and make them
available and stuff and assertion
assertion for me that's not the answer
that's not getting us anywhere right it
has problems by itself so far elsevier's
had a fairly aggressive going after
doing this fifteen percent at most in
many cases most that depends on how how
when what things you count between nine
and fifteen percent of papers in 2012
had any connie any kind of supplemental
file associated that most of those are
videos either the author talking about
it or something like that only one
percent had datasets that it now mind
you I've looked at the detail of all of
these but those are things that were
Excel spreadsheets or something like
that right only another one percent had
zip files which has multiple stuff
thrown together so we're talking about a
very small
that actually have and then though
there's no rules for putting those data
sets or whatever you do together with
the paper no rules some cases there's
review but mostly not right where is
that going and a lot of publisher not
publishers because publishers don't make
those rules about that but editors was
in charge of the journals are pulling
back from that saying this is not
getting us anywhere this is not
providing the value and in fact elsevier
the very aggressive policy of saying put
your data in a repository that is shared
that is open and will link to that and
we have a linking program there are 35
databases we link to today
bidirectionally from the paper to the
data set from the data set to the paper
to try to join these up and we have a
strong program for adding databases as
soon as we can process them and work
through them and get all of the the
api's and everything else sorted out and
that provides a much stronger value for
really connecting these things together
so anyway that's just an aside because I
think of that and as decide but maybe
I'm the one missing the boat here it
certainly could be issue number to
sustainability this is a probably mostly
familiar with the the research database
issue that comes out every year from
nucleic acids research this is the 2012
issue the 2013 issue just came out 2012
issue said there were 1380 databases in
this one discipline alone it seems like
there's an issue about joining them up
anyway there are 1380 databases growing
at between eight and ten percent the lat
the growth over your fifteen hundred and
twelve in the issue that was put out
just this month for this year that's a
nine and a half percent growth of
databases alone the data themselves are
growing over a hundred percent in that
one area here and this issue called out
the big issue concern that they had
which was funding sustainable funding
and they highlighted for databases that
were going out of business because there
is not continued funding for these
databases carrying them forward
databases are funded by grants by
research grants to do something new well
after their established they're not new
so where is the funding come from and
and I know this is a tricky thing for
for me elsevier to talk about funding
and models and business models and stuff
but I think we need to get this out on
the table
and I do think that there is something
that we can do together that can move us
forward so I've got some brainstorm
ideas for how to do that there's another
article from nature nature news last
year also and it highlighted these
databases that are also going out of
business that is that don't have any
funding going forward that just again
just one point the one point is we've
got to face up to the fact that this is
very expensive to do and I'll talk a
little bit about cost and where that
costs go and stuff but sustainability
there are many databases can we fund
this from a various different kinds of
models sorry for this busy slide this is
a slide that I created taken from a
study by JYSK that was done by Neil
beggary associates looking they surveyed
a bunch of data repository owners mostly
UK in Europe I think they did a couple
of in the US and said where are you
spending your time where is the money
going that's going into the sustaining
supporting these databases and a quarter
of the effort is going into the ingest
the ingest part that is taking the data
from the lab and getting it into the
database that's a lot of effort to do
that and it's a lot of effort to throw
onto the researcher to try to do and
that by itself as a barrier that effort
to do that requires skills different
skill sets different approach different
mindset taxonomy thinking informatics
thinking it's a different thing than
doing research and that's by itself is a
barrier and that's I think a key
takeaway from this then there's other
other things in there as well you can
look at this in your own time again an
excellent report by gist and Neal be
agree that Maya if you just look up just
keeping research data safe you'll get
report number one report number two good
reports to look at so pain points and
now just I'm not trying to give a a
pitch for elsevier and stuff but I think
we do have some things to offer
particularly in this space because of
the issues that I've highlighted that's
what I want to talk about elsevier or
rito severe parent and so forth has
strengths particularly in taxonomy maybe
many of you know this or don't know we
have 30 formal over 30 formal taxonomy
that we maintain in a variety of subject
areas across science that we are those
are the ones that we are owners of we do
ourselves for our own we do of course
indexing of every art
well that comes in manual in or
semi-automated indexing for every
subject that we publish in and of course
we publish in every subject we have
either taxonomy that we use and borrow
or we have tacked on amis that we've
created ourselves that add value to do
that we create special projects on top
of these taxonomies so this is in my
view one of our real core equity so we
have a whole group dedicated to content
enhancement that does taxonomy
maintenance indexing and applying
standard nomenclatures to content and
data and we do this for databases as
well and I think other publishers again
this is not unique to LC or all
publishers do this as part of the effort
that they do we also do at scale
analytics whether you are familiar with
some of our colleagues Medeia i'm not
going to go in and talk about the detail
of these but we do very large very large
scale analytics in open public data and
in medical records data and so forth and
publish the analytics at the end of that
we also tricky tricky part i how i
phrase is how we put this out but we
also take freely available data not weak
but i mean many companies take freely
available data and turn those into task
specific applications that is
applications that are ready for a not a
researcher but a corporate use to solve
a particular task right so turn a bunch
of data about manufacturing and create a
database specifically helping a
researcher and I'm not a researcher a a
designer answer the question about what
is the right plastic to put into this
harsh environment that's a targeted
answer and that actually is a way to get
money out of the free data and I think
that's where one of the points I'm going
to and we have a couple of things that
we do in in that area and so now just a
quick little about you know what we're
doing now I'm heading a new group called
research data services and elsevier
Anita a devourer is my colleague and
many of you probably know her a lot
better than you know me because she's
been involved in data stuff and future
of research and future communications
for for a long time and we are the
research data services group
looking at hey these are key problems is
there a way we can help get at these key
problems key principles right to start
with right so what are our goals
increased data has shared increase the
value of the data their shared right so
not just get it out there but
particularly focusing on increasing the
value and breaking down the barriers to
getting the data shared right and then
also looking at okay how can we get this
sustainable how can we create process
tools whatever it takes to make the
ingest getting the content in more
sustainable and also maybe provide some
more funding in some way for the for the
databases themselves the principle open
data let's please get that out on the
table here this is not in any way
talking about elsevier ownership of data
elsevier you know copyrighted at nothing
to do with that this is not anything
that we're talking about we're not
talking to any database owners about
taking over the databases or anything
like that we are working with database
owners to say okay how can we help move
it forward right but this is not about
owning or copyright or any of those
issues around data we are fully
believers in open shared data for the
academic community collaboration
collaborative that is we're not going to
do something we're not trying to create
an idea push it out there and say what
do you think we're working every time
this year is spent in working specific
collaborations with the academic
community to see how we can move forward
and being transparent about what we're
doing and including the business models
research data management is a
complicated thing that's sort of like
the overall big picture I'm not going to
go into diving in the details of it but
if you look at all the different parts
of the data life cycle we're talking
about taking care of data from beginning
to end you could be called a research
data management whole business and
there's lots of lookup research data
management on on Google today and you'll
get every universe every large
University has their own program
starting from scratch on research data
management on how to take care of this
from end to end all i want to say here
is that we have specific pilots aimed at
understanding what's going on in each of
these parts and how we might help move
forward by pilot i mean working together
with a research community or university
to say what can we do to add value
specifically looking at that
and then again I'm not going to go
through all these in detail but these
are the pilots you can look at the stuff
later and I want to highlight one of
them that we have a poster on Anita and
Kirsten have a poster on the project
that we're doing with Aida try and
earthcam trying to take data from the
laboratory get it into the repository
see what that takes see what skills that
need to see what process that needs see
what effort that needs and where are we
going to go with that and and by the way
we're not there's there's no financial
thing we're talking about what does it
take this year to do that we'll worry
about what comes after that when we
figure out what it takes and then how do
we make that sustainable that's what
we're trying to do here and then again
around the circle we have pilots in all
of these areas looking at what can we do
what where can we add value again given
the stuff that we had before so we've
got little slides on what the benefits
are for these X you I think we have a
flyer in your packet that has the
research data search so this is the
disclosure service that we're creating
they were piloting to see if there's a
process a place for us to help out for
this end and so we've got the listing of
what the benefits are four for the
researcher I want to talk final final
effort on one point here and that's the
funding models for sustainable databases
this is sort of a really messy little
slide but sort of like what how do the
databases get funded today right there's
a lot of money coming from funding
bodies going to the academic researchers
and then there's also money that goes
directly into the data repositories and
the academic institutions themselves add
money the data repositories and then the
white is the free you deposit your stuff
for free and you get your data out for
free and by the way we let corporates
get all of that data for free as well
that's nice what could we do what we
could do instead and this is actually
starting already starting to happen
especially of the with the new a lot of
a lot of organs a I've got good really
good examples we don't have time to go
into but one simple model is the sort of
open access gold open access model right
pay to deposit your data that's going to
take an estimated well depends on who
you talk to but that may take here's a I
attended a conference the International
data curation conference in january and
am sir
and we there was a special workshop on
the cost of doing these databases and
the estimate that came out of that group
was that it can take ten percent average
ten percent of the cost of the research
data itself I mean of the research
funding itself to maintain these
databases to keep that going if you add
that number up it gets pretty big fast I
saw one estimate from marine Explorer
companies looking at marine data and
just in that area alone they estimate
five Giga site five billion dollars a
year to take care of the data to do that
so a gold open access model means
increasing all of the funding bottles
right up front by ten percent
interesting model not sure this is right
but what we do today there's lots of
companies who are making money taking
especially in translational medicine
taking data in drug trial dot at data
matching it up with individual genomic
profiling and getting predictive
biomarkers of whether this person is
going to have an adverse effect by that
drug in in that trial and selling that
back to Pharma they're taking the freely
available data and selling it back one
of the ideas we could do is say together
maybe we could build some of those
analytic services or some of those task
oriented analytics and then license the
data back to the repository so charge
the corporates for uses for those data
where we can and then charge the licence
fee past the license feedback to help
fund the database this actually works
quite well in many areas right now we
let all the other companies go out and
build these analytics and we don't
charge them a licence fee for using the
data that they're that they're getting
that they're making their their whole
business out of interesting idea anyway
this was a interesting point I heard at
the end of near the end of that
conference somebody said we can't do
this by yourself they're talking about
building models for sustainable funding
model we can't do this by ourselves we
need somebody with business savvy to
work with us go that's my talk
you